Hi, I'm Richard Bartrem, Vice President of Communications for WestJet.
Here is some exciting news.
Effective today, we're introducing child-free cabins on board select flights.
We've heard from many of our guests...
...that they're tired of kids screaming and running up and down the aisle...
...and are looking quite simply for some peace and quiet.
So, you may be asking, "How do I get my children to their destination?"
Well, that's a great question and we've got a great answer.
We call it "Kargo Kids."
Let's take a look at the process.
When you arrive at the airport, simply ask for Kargo Kids when you check in.
Our friendly WestJet customer service agents are more than happy to help.
They'll assist you in getting your child ready for their trip on a travel toboggan.
Your child will be whisked away in a magic carpet ride and your work is done.
Meanwhile, our WestJetters are hard at work.
Your child's toboggan will arrive safely with the luggage...
...and other kids who will be boarding that flight.
From there, one of our friendly WestJetters will take the children to their waiting flight.
On board each flight, we have a Kargo Kids counselor...
...who's there to make sure that your kids are well taken care of and supervised.
With plenty of toys and a state-of-the-art feed trough,...
...your children will be able to run and play, scream and eat all they want...
...while you enjoy your flight in peace and quiet.
So book Kargo Kids today by going to westJet.com/kargokids,...
...that's "Kargo" and "Kids" with a "K"...
...and let us give you the peace and quiet you need.
From all of us at WestJet, you're welcome.
Happy April Fools' from WestJet!
Look for your savings below.
Good job.